Donald Trump did not do nothing that
weekend he did go to the big Turning
Point annual conference uh and here's a
bit of his speech that was only the
beginning with your support in 2024 we
are going to put America First like
never before and we are going to finish
the job that we so successfully started
you know many people it was four years
but many people say it was one of the
most successful presidencies ever some
people say it was the most successful
presidency when I get back into the Oval
Office I will totally obliterate the
Deep State they will be obliterated
I don't know some of it again I voted
for him and I like him in a lot of
respects it just it's starting to seem
like this rerun that I've seen a million
times before but but Brian this concept
of that he'll get the Deep State this
time look he did a pretty freaking good
job as president especially the those
first two and a half years uh but in the
end he did award fouchy on the way out
the the Deep State seemed to have gotten
him as a as a former three-letter guy in
the CIA like do you think he knows what
he's up against does anyone really know
what he's up against well I don't think
he or any of these guys yeah fair look I
think in 2016 he certainly didn't know I
think the folks around him didn't have
any understanding of how bad it was
going to be and then he was basically
thrown into the wood chipper by these
guys at the FBI the agency and others
and so I think that he's been pretty
Barn pretty heavily I think everybody in
the country knows how bad those
organizations have got those mid-level
those senior level individuals the James
comey's the Christopher Rays now we've
got some more reports from inspector
generals and special counsels that said
these guys were up to no good so I I
think that there is now a wind at his
back for the conversation that the
country has to have and has been
happening that we need some pretty
serious reform and we need to toss a lot
of folks out of office so the real
question is going to be does he have the
support on Capitol Hill to do that you
know that's going to be yeah I think
something I'll be looking for certainly
the next day after we all vote who
controls the house in the Senate because
that power of the purse is going to be
very important I know that he's looking
at his team or looking at executive
orders to toss out a lot of of you know
mid-level you know Folks at their will
or their whim maybe they'll be able to
do that I think it's called schedule F
or something at iterate the point is you
know they're they're looking at doing uh
what they need to do to clean the join
up um it's got to be done I think most
of us now understand that does he have
the Congressional you know back backing
to do that particularly with the power
of the purse that's the part that I
think really that will shape this whole
conversation can he actually do what
he's saying he wants to do Michael
putting aside the power of the person
whether the Republicans have Congress
and Senate and all the stuff do you
think he can staff with the right people
that can do this thing I mean that's
what I'm actually it look I have said
this a million times even though I
obviously am supporting DeSantis if at
the end of this Trump is President and
DeSantis is my Governor I will be fine I
guarantee you I will be fine and that
way and I will gladly vote for Trump and
that will be it my concern with the
Trump presidency at this point though is
that he will get there and nobody is
going to want to work for him for good
reason
personnel has been a problem for Trump
he's had some real stars but it by his
own admission he's had some real
Clunkers in there and and so my most out
of the box thought if the polls remain
as they are if Trump becomes the nominee
I know a lot of people are saying
DeSantis should be VP I think we both
know neither of those guys
at the very least DeSantis as Chief of
Staff would not be the worst idea
because the the real shining Mark for
DeSantis here is he knows personnel and
he knows how to wield power and he's
done it on a smaller stage in Florida
but that would be the thing that Trump
is talking about right now how do you
wield power on the personnel and the
issue is the Deep State depending on how
you count the bureaucracy just employees
for the federal government is like two
million people it is just so many many
people even Under the Umbrella of the
DHS you're talking about a quarter
million people and so in order to make
substantial change in there you would
have to switch out forty to fifty
thousand people just to start to get the
engine and Machinery moving in the right
direction again